21 juillet 1969
j'ai six mois dans le ventre de ma mère
lorsque je reçois cette voie lunaire en
direct premiers pas de l'homme sur la
lune enfant j'ai ce rêve devenir pilote
de chasse puis astronautes comme des
milliers d'enfants
je rêve d'extraordinaire de sensations
fortes de dépassement dans l'inconnu
comme le capitaine kirk dans son
vaisseau enterprise ou chuck jaeger qui
le premier a passé le mur du son je veux
faire ce que font les hérauts aider les
autres me dépassant être reconnu mais à
huit ans ils ont brisé mon rêve en mille
morceaux
j'ai dû porter des lunettes tous les
jours adieu l'astronaute
adieu le pilote de chasse j'ai dû
trouver une nouvelle voie
passé cette barrière alors en juillet 93
jeu devient ingénieur
ce que j'aime dans le monde juniors
c'est ingénieux qui pensent en dehors du
cadre qui trouve des solutions
quelle que soit la situation ma
spécialité l'innovation appliquée dans
les milieux les plus complexes les plus
variées et vous votre spécialité
ça m'intéresse pas ce que nous allons
partir en voyage ensemble dans trois de
mes monde
les hélicoptères réacteurs des centrales
nucléaires et un record du monde
en sports extrêmes à haute vitesse pour
cela j'ai besoin de chacun de vous alors
en 94 g 24 ans avec mes lunettes
je suis jeune ingénieur je sors de mon
école je pars aux états unis chercheurs
scientifiques
un beau sujet mais je suis seul je suis
terrorisée je parle très mal anglais je
vais dans le plus grand des labos qui
travaille sur les hélicoptères et ce
sont les meilleurs chercheurs du monde
j'ai découvert le sujet a seulement deux
mois le sujet mon sujet l'interaction
des pâles avec les tourbillons qui sont
émis à leur extrémité
l'apal tourne elle crée un tourbillon et
l recroise son tourbillon
et ça ça fait un choc bas aérodynamique
très violent c'est pour ça qu'il ya pas
d'hélicoptère dans les villes trop de
bruit boum boum boum boum je dois
étudier ce sujet dans l'université
c'est très simple
la communication à midi chinois ou
mexicains parle pas c'est des mails en
94 encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs gestion
alors d'un côté il ya ma famille des
tourbillons le départ on travaille que
sur les tourbillons leur naissance leur
vie de l'autre côté je découvre qu'il ya
des gens qui travaillent sur les pales
d'hélicoptères qui cherchent à tordre
les pales au maximum savent pas pourquoi
mais il tord de l'epal au maximum super
mais ce n'est pas mon sujet et puis il
ya les aéro acousticien alors eu les
calculs ce que font les autres et savoir
le bruit que va faire l'hélicoptère le
sujet c'est une barrière pour moi je
tourne en rond au bout de deux mois je
suis aux limites de la connaissance je
creuse ça n'avance pas cette barrière je
veux avancer je veux trouver autre chose
alors je commence à regarder ailleurs
je pense autrement et si mes amis des
tourbillons ont donné des consignes à
nos voisins des pales qui communiquent
pas alors disant voilà quand je
m'approche tourbillon je bouge m'appelle
comme ça
le choc aérodynamique va diminuer
peut-être que l'aéro acoustique va dire
super on baisse le bruit effectivement
on se met tous à travailler ensemble
derrière mon idée c'est validé douze
mois après on valide que ce bruit
peut-être la faisabilité on parle à dix
ans peut-être diminué par quatre énormes
l'enjeu est énorme ces nouveaux champs
en fait le nouveau champ de recherche
s'intéresse tout le monde
une publication je pars au texas parler
de tout ça c'est un succès je suis jeune
ingénieur là dedans je suis touché par
ça on peut faire bouger les lignes
pendant quinze ans cette publication va
être reprise par d'autres
alors on va changer de monde parce que
le temps presse on va partir dans un
autre monde celui du nucléaire
24 mai 2015
dimanche soir veille de week-end pascal
de lundi de pâques un appel de marque du
centre d'ingénierie du parc nucléaire me
dit mark papa de parfaits marque
on a un gros problème il faudrait
peut-être que tu nous amènes une
solution on sait pas quoi faire
c'est quand même curieux l'entreprise
ceux qui interviennent ces deux cent
mille personnes dans le monde dont
m'appelle mois souci est quand même
majeurs nous avons un arrêt tranche
réacteur est arrêté le combustible a été
évacué l'eau dans la piscine où se
trouve le réacteur qui le protège est
enlevé et ce réacteur a le ventre à
l'air va avoir le ventre à l'air dans
cinq jours
l'air à l'intérieur avec des poussières
contaminées peut s'échapper dans le
bâtiment réacteur et contaminer tout le
bâtiment réacteur
ça veut dire arrêt de la tranche dans
cinq jours
ça leur coûte un million d'euros par
jour qu'est ce que je fais le plus
simple pour moi c'est de reculer
non on va y aller on a cinq jours pour
faire un petit exploit
il faut trouver une solution de
technique on trouve la solution on met
en place la procédure j'ai créé la
procédure et puis on va faire ce voyage
dans le bâtiment tous ensemble tantôt
rend dans une centrale nucléaire
la première chose vous imaginez on va
badges et puis on va rebadgée pulvar au
badge et pur badges et puis on arrive à
un endroit c'est investir avant de
rentrer ce qu'on dit en zone à
l'intérieur du bâtiment réacteur
c'est normal c'est vachement sympa ça
vous met en condition c'est un vestiaire
hommes femmes
par contre on se met ainsi tout ce je ne
sais pas si on a un badge on a un
dosimètre qui va mesurer la
contamination qui on arrive dans cette
porte c'est la dernière entrée dans le
bâtiment réacteur
on est toujours ainsi puis en badges je
n'espère qu'une chose c'est que quand on
appuie sur le bouton ça s'ouvre c'est
que derrière on va pouvoir s'habiller
effectivement s'habiller en blanc on
arrive dans le bâtiment réacteur et là
je vous avoue que je suis pas quand même
tranquille parce que j'écris une
procédure j'ai visualisé la procédure la
technique est ok c'est bon mais là on
passe dans un autre monde
il va falloir aller au fond et c'est moi
qui vais devoir aller au fond tout seul
parce qu'il faut faire dans ma procédure
des noeuds des noeuds pour couvrir ce
réacteur que l'on voit là la zone est
contaminée je dois m'approchais rentrer
à l'intérieur je mets des choses j'ai
mis une combinaison ont protégé la
contamination
je mets un micro et des écouteurs parce
que je vais être seul en bas je vais
communiquer avec vous là aux jeux
dessins au fond dans cet environnement
là et c'est ça qu'on voit dix mètres
d'inox au dessus de la tête ça grésille
je suis pas je suis pas fiers du tout je
suis pas bien du tout et pourtant il
faut faire le job donc je fais ce que
j'ai prévu dans la procédure et je
voulais l'ambiance spatiale mais là j'ai
mon ambiance martial g / chaufferont
j'ai mon truc c'est bon ça dure le temps
qu'il faut j'ai quinze minutes parce que
je la radioactivité de ce bâtiment là ce
sera acteur qui fait que je dois rester
à plus d'un mètre ce que mon compteur
mesure ce que je prends comme 2 la
radioactivité est partout on la voit pas
mais elle est là je fais ce que j'ai à
faire et puis là au siv elle perd du
temps je m'énerve et je prends sur moi
et puis j'observe autour de moi cet
environnement-là 7 inox
j'imagine le combustible qui sort du
réacteur qui étaient évacués qui
remplaçait c'est magique
quelle fierté d'avoir pu juste avec des
hommes avec la volonté être allé
jusque-là avoir pu faire quelque chose
qui paraissait impossible seulement il
ya cinq jours
pourtant ça c'est fait c'est possible
alors on va changer de monde partir dans
une autre sphère
justement juste quelques semaines de
ceux de cet événement là mon ami eric
baronne champion de vtt sports extrêmes
14 records du monde en 2000 bat un
record du monde de vitesse en vtt avec
222 km heure sur neige
vous avez peut-être vu ces images à la
télé un bonhomme en rouge qui descend
très vite et à l'époque j'avais
travaillé qu avec lui je vais rencontrer
à toulouse d'ailleurs quelques années
avant j'avais fait le design
aérodynamique du vélo donc je sais que
ce vélo était un prototype et qu'il est
très performant très performant et en
eric l'envoie là en rouge me dit écoute
je veux me ré attaquer à nouveau à mon
record de 2000 il ressort d'un très
grave accident en 2002 et il repartait
dans l'aventuré
je sais que le challenge est énorme
qu'est ce que je fais je dois réfléchir
10 secondes 10 secondes et puis ok on y
va j'ai deux rôles l'ingénierie du vélo
et puis de notre côté le management des
hommes sur place pour le libérer
mentalement la technique est parti ça y
est le projet démarre sa part comme sa
feuille blanche on s'appuie sur notre
connaissance on s'appuie sur les
nouvelles technologies il faut imaginer
le vélo de nos rêves alors on le dessine
on dessine ce vélo tout doucement très
bas allonger des grands droits l'avoir
l'arrière des petites suspension une
bête de course
dans notre tête ça c'est un dessin on
réalise une base de vélo une matrice de
vélos et vtt
ça ressemble à un invité spécial mais ça
ressemble à vtt homérique de sur le scan
ont fait des calculs 75 passes de calcul
75 carénage différents pour arriver à
ceux ci quarante mille heures pour ceux
qui aiment bien les chiffres 40
milliards de calculs sur des preuves des
machines 24 ans c'est énorme
dix ans c'était impossible à faire puis
derrière on arrive à ceci le vélo animal
l'ergonomie qui fait pour battre des
records
on sait que c'est une formule 1 puis
quand on me éric dessus ça fait ça
on est encore plus loin la technique top
super soufflerie super tout marche
nickel mais la technique qu'il faut
l'oublier très vite quand on veut faire
genre de choses je vous passe pas la
photo éric a pas voulu
il est en caleçon là dessus aussi pour
vingt et a pas voulu commettre la faute
la réalité elle est là maintenant on
passe dans autre chose dans l'émotionnel
ici dans la pente alors on va imaginer
ça parce qu'il faut se mettre dans la
tête du champion qui va faire son record
on est là pour l'amener à le faire il
faut penser comme lui alors je vais vous
demander d'y participer vous allez
regarder votre voisin pendant 10
secondes les yeux dans les yeux
maintenant vous imaginez qu'en face de
vous c'est moi qui suis là qui va vous
mettre le casque sur la tête
vous avez le casque d'eric sur la tête
ben c'est penser penser concentrez-vous
maintenant vous revenez vers moi écoutez
on est au départ trois 2 1 go on est sur
le vélo comme ceux ci on est libéré on
est comme en chute libre
la première partie du durant le premier
tiers la piste est bosselée
on était en appui sur les pieds et on
doit stabiliser c'est du pilotage est
pas d'aérodynamique après un tiers à 180
km heure on tire vers la droite comme on
a vu la reconnaissance hier en tire vers
la droite
et là on va se mettre sur la piste qui
la plus régulière et là il faut changer
le mindset il faut changer l'état
d'esprit on pousse sur les genoux devant
on bloque le bassin derrière comme idée
là et on regarde que la roue avant à 220
km heure ok vous êtes prêts
pensez à ça ce qu'on va vivre maintenant
28 mars 2015
nous sommes en haut de la piste de
kilomètre lancé de vars 2700 mètres
d'altitude
nuit noire -20° ressenti 70 km heure
devant latéral rafale c'est glacial
je suis
pas bien j'ai en charge tout ça c'est
moi qui vais décider
on prépare la plate forme de départ
voyez tout se met en place grand pont à
glace cordages de sécurité sont prêts à
partir tension est maximale
le van basten tout petit peu je dis ok
pour le départ on va y aller on va
chercher eric il nous rejoint on y va
vous êtes prêts vous êtes prêts
ok enfin c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure
on est en position
ok
ce prêt
notamment trois centimètres
record battu
on est dans ces conditions
merci à tous nous remercier
c'est bon ça c'est énorme
alors imaginez ces moments c'est juste
après le record 10 minutes
ça
votre succès les succès qu'il a pu avoir
pour ressentez ce moment vous avez fait
le travail
vous êtes bien vous êtes en paix avec
vous même ces profondes l'émotion
intense
c'est peut-être la joie simple profondes
de ces héros de l'ombre de ceux qui
aident les autres à se réaliser
alors c'est une énorme émotion pour moi
défi de me livrer vous raconter ma vie
comme ceci parce que je dois dépasser
mes propres émotions mes propres
barrières émotionnel c'est grâce à mes
héroïnes de l'ombre à moi alors à huit
ans ils ont brisé mon rêve
j'ai dû porter des lunettes c'est vrai
mais c'est aujourd'hui que je réalise
que grâce à cela j'ai pu franchir
d'autres barrières accéder à d'autres
rêvent tous les jours peut-être encore
plus fou ses rêves dans deux jours j'ai
45 ans je réalise que je devenu le héros
de ma propre existence
tantôt dans l'on entend dans la lumière
et peu importe au fond sommes tous nous
pouvons tous être le héros de quelqu'un
et vous deux qui est voulu et on